Thank You mr. chairman and I have two
questions mr. Greenspan but I'd like to
put them in a context and the context is
that it seems to me chairman leach that
this committee and this Congress should
begin to take a hard look at the failure
of long-term capital within a broader
context of what's going on in our
country our end throughout the world and
that is reflective I think in some of
the policies that mr. Greenspan and his
colleagues have long advocated which
have led us to a situation in which
fewer and fewer people with unheard of
wealth now have enormous power over the
global economy and the lives of billions
of people and the bottom line is that
when those folks fair and those folks
collapse they take a whole lot of people
with them and we should really begin to
look at the process and how we got to
where we are today and question whether
that is the direction that we want to
continue going in now I for one of for
example are am very concerned about the
extraordinarily unfair distribution that
exists of wealth not only in our country
but throughout the world and i'm going
to ask mr. greenspan a question about
this a moment in a moment but according
to the united nations mr. chairman the
world's 225 richest individuals have a
combined wealth of over a trillion
dollars equal to the bottom forty seven
percent of the world's population 225
people have as much wealth as almost
half of the world's population further
we are now living at a time where of the
100 largest economies in the world 51 of
them are private corporations again run
by a handful of individuals when we look
at institutions like the IMF we find
that a handful of bureaucrats at the IMF
have life and death power over dozens
and dozens of countries throughout the
world when we look at what's happening
in our own country not to mention the
rest of the world
we see in industry after industry
whether is the banking industry whether
it is the media whether it is
telecommunications what we see our
merger after merger after merger and
fewer and fewer corporations run by
smaller and smaller groups of
individuals who control more and more of
the market and when these people make a
mistake those are mistakes heard all
over the world which affect the lives of
billions of people and I think that
laissez-faire attitude that mr.
Greenspan his colleagues have had
created are leading us into a very very
dangerous situation now my question for
mr. Greenspan is a very simple one in
the United States of America today you
have one man who owns more wealth than
100 million Americans in the world you
have 225 people who own more wealth than
almost half the world's population does
that concern you do you think that is
just and not only in terms of justice
and morality aren't you concerned about
the economic instability that can occur
when so few have so much power and when
mistakes are made such as with long-term
capital looking at the economic
repercussions of what a few people can
do does that concern you mr. Greenspan
well if you're asking me what I prefer
that there was less concentration of
income less concentration of wealth I
would say yes generally I would and I
would would because I believe that
democratic institutions tend to function
best when you have fairly even
distributions the question I think which
is crucial to your i should say the
issue which is crucial to your question
is what would you do about it and to
what extent would that improve the state
of being of the world at large and the
individuals who don't have that wealth
it's not by any means clear to me that
if you were somehow to take these 225
individuals and merely indicate to them
that they no longer have any wealth and
you put them away on a desert island
that the state of the rest of the world
would be improved in the slightest if
you're asking me to individuals who have
significant power and when they make
mistakes does it have consequences to
others that's always been the case
throughout history I think we ought to
instead of looking at what we are what
we have now as some incredibly corrupt
unequal unethical system is to try to
look at what the United States has
become relative to what used to exist
100 to 300 years ago I would say to you
that the standard of living at the
average American is dramatically higher
that the average American is far better
off than at any time in our history and
I would suggest to you that that
particular state would not be improved
by confiscating the wealth of the every
billionaire in the United States someone
suggested that but by the way you
mentioned the moment ago about how I
believe I I remembering what you said
that the United States has the highest
standard of living in the world this is
a country we have 43 million of
Americans with no health insurance we
have a situation where the typical
married couple family work 247 more
hours in 1996 that in 1989 where real
wages have declined in the real last 20
years but be that I made my second
question mr. Chairman I think it's
important for our banking committee
because this issue ties into HR 10 now
mr. Greenspan as you know the Fed
recently approved the acquisition of
citicorp by travels we all know that
citibank is heavily involved in
developing countries developing markets
a highly troubled sector to say the
least travelers reported large losses
during the recent market turmoil and is
now reported to be a major investor in
term capital why shouldn't we be
concerned that allowing combinations
like Citigroup increases overall risk
for financial institutions rather than
decreasing risk which takes us through
the whole issue of HR 10 and making it
easier for large banks to merge with
other types of companies mr. Greenspan
well first of all let me just say we
process the application according to the
law according to what the statute under
which those applications require we made
judgments in all regard we made
judgments about the nature of the merger
and when we believe that all
requirements of the law were met we
approved it as we are required to do if
you're asking the broader question about
these larger institutions one of the
reasons why for example we after
thinking about it for a while decided
that the basket the ability of
institutions to have very substantial
interplay between the non-financial part
of the economy and the financial part
which would be significantly enhanced
under for some of the early versions of
HR 10 why we opposed and in retrospect I
think correctly HR 10 has passed by the
House of Representatives in my judgment
was a very good bill the issue of making
certain that all of the new powers are
required to be financed in the
marketplace at competitive rates and
therefore through an affiliate of a
holding company as distinct from as was
originally discussed in many different
versions of the bill
through subsidiaries of the bank i would
say that one of the reasons why we are
very much concerned that indeed all of
these powers be in the holding companies
is that we are worried about the issue
of subsidies coming out of the bank into
the subsidiary of the bank and being
used in a non-competitive manner to
employ expansion of powers which are in
HR 10 so the answer is yes I am I am a
little concerned about some of the size
of these various institutions and I
think it's very important that we make
certain that we don't subsidize them
Thank You mr. grits mr. Chairman I would
just conclude by suggesting I think this
isn't important here and I think it lays
the groundwork for future hearings in
which we should take a hard look at the
degree of concentration of ownership in
this country and the implication for our
national and international economy thank
you I thank the gentleman I would only
add as the jungle is noted that in
theory the particular bailout the Fed
has put together does involve a massive
amount of concentration of power in one
particular hedge fund and this is a very
concerning situation mr. castle